this episode is brought to you by fresh
books thousands of listeners
and a lot of the contractors i use and
my readers use freshbooks
if you've been thinking about turning
your part-time side business into a
full-time small business or big business
for that matter
you may be feeling some extra
uncertainty these days and
that's obviously completely natural
there are a lot of questions that can
come up how do you create a professional
appearance and experience who can help
you with support how do you manage the
billing and all of that but still focus
on the primary work of your business and
on growing your business
freshbooks is an all-in-one invoicing
and accounting solution
it does a lot more than that that helps
you take your business from part-time to
full-time and it only takes
minutes to set up they have one of the
best sign-up flows
in the business i've seen very few
better they have been helping people
turn their passions into small
businesses for 15 years
and they can help you too i've met the
founders i've looked at this product
very closely with automated invoicing
billable time and expense tracking
and an intuitive dashboard that ties it
all together it's like having a
full-time financial assistant with you
every step
of the way you can create customize and
send branded and professional looking
invoices in about 30 seconds
you get paid up to twice as fast with
fees as low
as one percent using ach payments on
freshbooks
it's a fast easy and secure way for
clients to pay you for your work
and pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets freshbooks apart is
their award-winning toronto-based
customer service
a real person picks up fast and will
help you until
you are completely satisfied and have
your questions answered
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
world right now but your ability to
build a business
that you're passionate about that you're
proud of doesn't have to be one of those
things
business owners all over the world rate
freshbooks as the easiest accounting
software to use
try it out check it out for free for 30
days at freshbooks.com
tim just enter tim ferriss in the how
did you hear about us section
again that's freshbooks.comtim to check
it out and try it for free for 30 days
one more time
freshbooks.com tim
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost
of traditional stores so i'm sitting in
my living room right now and it's
entirely all form furniture i've got two
chairs i've got an ottoman
and i have an l sectional couch and i'll
come back to that
you can pick your fabric they're all
spill stained and scratch resistant the
sofa color
the color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an 8
seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use
the natural leg finish which is their
lightest color and
i dig it i mean i've been using these
things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky you don't need to
worry
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home with fast free shipping
and you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked
much better than i could have imagined
and i'm very very happy so
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout at this altitude i can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start to shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is my job always
to deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types to tease out the
habits routines
favorite books whatever that you can
test and apply
in your own lives my guest today i'm
very excited to have on finally
stephen ranella r-i-n-e-l-l-a you can
find him on instagram
at meat eater also at steven ranella
stephen with v
he is the host of the netflix original
series meat-eater and the meat-eater
podcast he's also the author of seven
books dealing with wildlife conservation
hunting fishing and wild foods including
a forthcoming book
the meat eater guide to wilderness
skills and survival coming out december
1st 2020
you can find all things meat eater on
themeateater.com
and you can also find steven on facebook
at stevenranella
meet eater steve so nice to have you on
the show thanks for coming on
thank you that was a good delivery there
man
that was a great hosting
well you know we we met i was trying to
do the math on it
and i'm guessing i want you to correct
me if i'm wrong but i want to say maybe
mid to late 2011
and i was trying to do a trip down
memory lane it's almost 10 years
since we first met which is just bonkers
and
i promised that if i screwed up the
intro i would
not make you suffer through 20 retakes
and that i would fix any flubs later
but it seems like lifetimes ago that we
first met in the context of the four
hour chef
and i thought perhaps a trip down
memory lane at least as i've been doing
prep for this there's been quite a bit
of that could be fun for setting the
stage because
there's certainly going to be some
listeners of this podcast
who have hunted and there are going to
be many many who have not
and i wanted to read just a tiny little
piece from
the first chapter i had someone on my
team pull
everywhere you appeared in the four hour
chef it was like
a quarter of the book so i only dug into
a few pieces but there's a chapter
called the anti-hunters
first hunt the anti-hunter referring to
me because i grew up on long island
having
very bad associations with the hunters
who did a very poor job
in my neighborhood and around my house
where i grew up but
you are the counterpoint so i wanted to
set the stage i'm going to skip things a
little bit but the heading is 6 a.m
south carolina and then i'll skip down
stephen ellis tutelage and all things
hunting was encyclopedic my 6 a.m brains
struggled to absorb a motley assortment
of miscellaneous
point deer are classified as crepuscular
in simple terms they move mostly at dawn
and at dusk
point kiefer sutherland was once
swindled in a cattle wrestling ponzi
scheme
i'd forgotten that one point if steve
could only eat one meat for the rest of
his life
let me know if this has changed a
monthly 50-pound allotment of any wild
or domesticated animal it would
absolutely be elk specifically cow elk
or young bull elk point the original
version of the joy of cooking had
instructions for how to fatten a trapped
opossum with milk and cereals for 10
days before slaughtering and cooking it
point the neck of a male deer in mating
mode in other words a
ruddy buck in quotation marks can double
in size making it look like a linebacker
point skinning a rabbit is easier than
taking off your socks grab the scruff
and peel pulling down towards the head
eating rabbit requires caution though as
you can die from tularemia and
infectious disease named after tulare
county in california
steve is his downturn this won't go too
terribly long so bear with me
steve is as down to earth as you would
hope any good hunter to be but he didn't
fit my stereotype for instance he
applies physics terms to skinning and
most relevant to my food quest as he put
it quote there are far better chefs out
there than me there are far better
hunters out there too but there aren't
many who can combine the two like i do
he is a master of turning the wild into
quote ingredients people recognize now
i'm going to need some french help
in 2004 he prepared a three-day 45
course
so i'll let that sink in for people a
three-day 45 course banquet from
escoffier's landmark
1903 classic is it la la guide culinaire
how do you have no idea how to say that
properly say what i do
i say that the culinary guide the
culinary guide
nice all right and then the last the
last paragraph
i'll read here is by prepare i mean that
he foraged killed and otherwise procured
every ingredient from the outdoors then
recreated the feast himself which took
more than a week
this experiment was chronicled in his
first book now here's another french
word
the scavenger's guide to haute cuisine
h-a-u-t-e
i've been well trained in this one and
still every time you do it you'll get
corrected
without the h all right scavenger's
guide to cuisine there you go
that was great that was great man i was
better than i did thank you you know you
know i've been i've been working on my
french on the set
he started trapping for income in rural
michigan when he was 10
now 38 that's of course changed he
writes for a living and his work is as
likely to be seen in the new york times
as in field and stream so i wanted to
set the stage because i think a lot of
people in their minds as soon as i
mentioned
hunting or anything else will have an
image pop up
and i don't think that image matches
you all that well at least the kind of
stereotypical image that will pop up for
non-hunters when i was younger i think
it would have matched me perfectly well
man
say more so i grew up in michigan but
across the lake you know not terribly
far away
it's at state of wisconsin and my good
friend pat durkin in wisconsin had once
said something along the lines of
you know where he lived that if you
weren't a deer hunter
you at least slept with one
[Laughter]
there wasn't a ton of you know there
wasn't a ton of self-reflection at the
time
and also raised up by a generation that
hadn't
been invited into and cultivated any
kind of real
conservation ethic and there was a bit
of a
get what's yours while you can get it
mentality
that i grew up on but i i don't want to
derail you i just you know i just get a
little bit maybe we'll touch on this
later
i often get you around me i often get
accused of being
um somehow different than
hunters or different than normal hunters
or different than what you'd expect as a
hunter and man like i feel like i'm a
lot like
the people that i spend a lot of time
with i'm a lot like a lot of the people
that i spend a lot of time with
let's dig into it so for instance in an
interview
that i read and prepped for this you
self-described as a hunter
conservationist right hyphenated and
i want to talk about that and i guess by
intro you the way that i did
what i wanted to point out and i'll just
personalize this is that
you know growing up my exposure to
hunters was very limited it was limited
to
seeing wounded deer with like arrows
like stuck in them on my property
my parents property because people were
a trespassing b
just not doing a very good job of
hunting understanding that
you're not going to have perfect shots
all the time but they're like beer cans
everywhere and it just wasn't a positive
association sure
now in contrast though at least if we
look at
i guess at the time 38 year old steve
who i went to south carolina with for my
first hunt
the experience and the explanation and
the care
and the attention to detail was
something
that i never would have associated with
hunting growing up
i suppose all i'm trying to do is
contrast those two things which were
largely an imaginary figure in my head
based on a few bits of
exposure as a kid and my experience with
you which were very very very different
and that's not to say that most hunters
are what i experienced as a kid
and not what you are but let's dig into
it like why do you call yourself if you
still do or identify as a hunter
conservationist
i absolutely do even sitting where i'm
at today so
you know you're reading from one you're
38 i'm 46
even sitting from where i am today when
i
look back at what our relationship
when i say our my families
the people i was around what our
relationship
was with nature in the out of doors
was very much based on
a deep deep love and appreciation
for resources for wild places for nature
it was almost like we would have never
put these words to
it but it was a sacred thing
and it was almost like a sort of worship
for
animals in a worship of wild places
but the perspective on it i didn't know
the history
of how things came to be the way they
were
we had a lot of national forest around
us we were sort of on the southern
terminus of
the manistee national forest i think now
it's the here on manistee national
forest it was combined with another
national forest
we were sitting at the southern terminus
of that national forest
i couldn't have told you the first thing
about how that
place came to be what sacrifices were
made
in our history to have the abundant
wildlife
that we had i couldn't have told you how
bad things had gotten
in this country in the late 1800s and
early 1900s
with regards to wildlife if there was a
sign
on that national forest it said close to
vehicular traffic if it wasn't
physically blocked
that would that sign wouldn't really
mean much to us if it looked like
somebody else
drove there we would drive there as well
i at times when faced with like an
abundant surplus of things
sold things for money that sold wild
game
for money knowing you weren't really
supposed to do that with some species
that we would sell
but it was a thing that people around
you did you didn't really know that it
was wrong
at the same time we would see behaviors
that we recognized
as abhorrent things that would probably
blow away any negatives that you
might have seen growing up i've probably
seen worse behaviors from
hunters and anglers than you have
so i always lived with a even if from my
perspective right now we had some poor
behaviors some
ill-thought behaviors i always
recognized the spectrum
of bad behavior and there were things
that would happen around us
that my father would be incensed about
and would like
disassociate with people who had
extraordinarily bad behavior
and if you look at that sense of there
being a spectrum of ethics or a spectrum
of a conservation ethos
throughout life with education and with
like various epiphanies that come
with just learning how to think and
having exposure to
books and ideas scientists biologists
ecologists
philosophers whatever it's become more
fine-tuned and i now have a very
acute sense of
what it takes to have wildlife in wild
places i have a good understanding of
that now i understand our history now
and that has led me to like an
extraordinary amount of reflection
over the years about what role a hunter
or an angler
should play when it comes to
environmental stewardship
and hunting so i associate as a
conservationist because i try to really
put
my money and actions where my mouth is
on conservation
meaning clean air clean water lots of
animals
lots of wildlife habitat those are
things i stand for and i see that that
is a thing that's increasing among my
kind but
it's a little tough for me to think of
myself as somehow extraordinary because
i see many many people go down the same
path
that i did a long exposure to this
seems to lead in this direction for most
people
for people who not only have no exposure
to
hunting themselves but who have no real
familiarity with
how hunting works in the u.s from an
economic
perspective the ecosystem not
necessarily the natural ecosystem but
sort of the
fiscal ecosystem i was reading an
article
and you seem to comment on the decline
in hunting and fishing license
sales as worrisome could you expand on
that or speak to that
i'd love to give people an idea like how
how funding works
how funding works exactly i would love
to this is something that there's a
catch 22 almost within this
but yeah i'd love to talk about that so
i know you have a global audience
i'm going to run down how it works in
the united states i can claim subject
matter expertise in the u.s and i have a
passing familiarity with other places
but i'm going to focus on the u.s
the u.s has 50 states right so all 50
states have a
state fish and game agency and your
state fish and game agencies
are responsible for the stewardship
of wildlife in your state there are
exceptions to this because
migratory birds some migratory fishes
and things
where what an animal isn't going to live
its entire life sort of in one
in in the confines of a particular state
then you'll have
federal oversight over what happens in
the state like there's sort of
some federal guidelines about how a
state might handle it's not its wildlife
resources
there's other exceptions too when you
get an endangered species act
and things like that but generally you
could say that the people in the state
own the wildlife in that state so if
you're sitting in
new york and you see a a deer
you as a new yorker own that deer
that deer is managed for you
by your state agency so it doesn't
matter what that deer is sitting in a
cemetery
if it jumps a fence into a county park
if it jumps a fence onto a farm
if it jumps a fence into a national
forest
that deers the states meaning it's yours
these agencies manage
wildlife in terms of access to it
oftentimes states manage like boat
launches and
trail heads on state lands and things
but they also do disease work on
wildlife
so they do re you know researching
diseases
wildlife management enforcement of
wildlife laws
so if someone's poaching that's a state
issue that all comes from your state
fish and game agency
some state fish and game agencies get no
hard funding
when you pay your taxes in your state in
a lot of states none of your general tax
money goes to your state fish and game
agency
the bulk of state fish and game agencies
finances come from the sale of
licenses tags and stamps hunting
licenses fishing licenses
permits tags all the stuff that goes
with hunting and fishing
and another major funding source
for state fish and game agencies is
excise taxes
on firearms ammunition
very use specific sporting goods items
marine gas fishing tackle fishing line
these excise taxes which can be like on
guns and ammo these excise taxes
come in at around you know 11 or 12
percent so when you go down and buy
even if some person that lives in new
york city goes down and buy and they
have a concealed
carry permit say and they go down and
buy some
ammo for a concealed carry permit about
11 or 12 percent of the
cost they pay on that ammo goes to fund
wildlife and that's how we pay for this
whole system
there are complexities to it but that's
how we pay for it a fear about
declining hunting and angling numbers
you know angry numbers
this is since coba they're seeing a
pretty strong uptick in
fishing numbers with people like i think
people weren't able to go do what they
would normally do they're like ah [ __ ]
it i'll go fishing
you know and we're seeing a fair bit of
that whether or not they'll be fishing
two years is
not known a fear about declining hunter
numbers and
i'll tell you an interesting point there
i think that there are about as many
hunters right now
as there were in the years following
world war ii and they were low after
world war two
well that was the peak in terms of per
capita
all those dudes this actually plays into
my i got to remember where i was at this
actually plays into my own sort of
genesis right is
my dad my dad had me he was old my dad
had me when he was 50.
he fought in world war ii and when he
came home from world war ii he
like just about every other guy that
went off and fought world war
ii got into hunting and fishing it was
sort of the that era the late 40s early
1950s
that was the birth of the modern
american
sportsmen people had money they were
buying cars
they were traveling around there was
this we were fetishizing the great
outdoors
and my dad was part of that generation
i'm saying hunting participation was so
high then i don't know
like i guess you could look up real
quick what the u.s population was in
1947 say but or 1950
but you know i think we've quadrupled
our population but we had about as many
hunters then as we have now
so participation rates decline in many
cases
numbers of people who hunt decline and a
long-term fear
besides whatever that might mean for
like a disassociation with nature and a
disassociation with wildlife
it has funding implications because
states even if you
hate hunters and anglers you can't get
around the fact that hunters and anglers
fund your state's wildlife apparatus
if people aren't doing those activities
anymore those funding structures fall
apart what are some of the components of
the wildlife apparatus like what are for
somebody
let's just say someone says hey i don't
care about hunting so why should i care
about this what
are some components pieces exactly i'll
give you a great for instance
anyone who hunts ducks anyone in this
country who hunts ducks
any kind of waterfowl migratory
waterfall ducks geese cranes whatever
besides buying your state license
state hunting license you usually need
like a base hunting license you need a
state
waterfowl permit you need to go buy
a federal duck stamp and for years the
federal duck stamp had been 15 bucks
it just raised up it raised up into the
20s
all of that money from all of those
millions of individuals buying those
federal duck stamps all of that money
goes in to fund
waterfowl habitat meaning it goes into
wetlands work anytime you if you have a
bear in your yard
let's say you realize that you have a
bear in your yard getting into your
garbage
when you call a number that's going to
be someone from your wildlife
agency is going to show up that wildlife
agency individual
will show up and when they show up their
salary equipment everything like their
agency is funded by expenditures from
hunters and anglers
so a fear is that if hunter numbers go
down
our ability to fund habitat work like
habitat improvement
habitat expansion habitat acquisition
wildlife work disease work reintroducing
species that were extirpated from the
landscape
that a lot of that work will lose its
funding structure and will go away
could you define extra p for people who
are not familiar with that word
yeah it's a great word i also want to
get into the catch-22 of this all
but yes yeah extirpate is people are
familiar with extinction right
extirpation is regional extinction
meaning
grizzly bears are abundant
grizzly bears are recovered in portions
of
wyoming okay wolves are recovered
in portions of wyoming wolves have been
extirpated from the bulk of their range
in the u.s
grizzly bears were extirpated from
california they're not extinct
but they're regionally extinct so you
could say that they were extirpated like
brought to regional extinction in
california
there's an ongoing bit of effort much of
it funded
by hunters for instance around
reintroducing species that were
extirpated through habitat destruction
over harvest for instance at a time new
mexico
had literally run out of elk they had
none
now they have thriving populations of
elk and elk hunting seasons
you know across the bulk of the state
but still with as many elk as we have
as much as we associate elk hunting and
seeing elk
elk are still missing from some 90
percent of their historic range
everywhere was elk habitat and they're
they're they've been extirpated they're
gone from those places
some of the work that's done by state
agencies and other like
wildlife groups many of them
hunter-based wildlife groups
is doing as much as we can to put those
animals back
where they belong if you think just like
if you look at it in terms of the turkey
at the time of european contact we had
wild turkeys in probably
39 states there's some debate about
where they were and it wasn't static
right like wildlife's dynamic you know
it expands its range its range shrinks
we probably had turkeys in 39 states by
the late 1800s early 1900s
we only had wild turkeys in 19 states
they vanished from 10.
only a couple states maintained any sort
of turkey season
most states it was illegal to touch a
turkey
we now have turkey hunting seasons in 49
states
so they did recovery and then some on
turkeys
and that was driven by hunters and you
could like and someone could sit and say
like
yeah you guys did that because you like
to hunt turkeys and i would say
yeah there's a lot of truth to that um
there's a lot of truth to that there was
an incentive to do it
but it was done you know and this is the
sort of work that go down
that you would lose if you lost that
funding mechanism
now the catch 22 is that
and this this is legitimate the catch-22
is that if hunter numbers go
down it's great for any individual
hunter who has less competition
you could live in a world where you're
the only guy that went out and hunted
you'd have a pretty sweet situation as
long as you had
public approval and didn't lose in the
legislative process
and hunting got banned everywhere which
would probably happen pretty quickly if
you were the only guy up to it
because there wouldn't be a lot of
people there like guarding the gate
right
so that's the catch-22 like that's the
hard part of this some people find it
deeply offensive
well-intentioned well-reasoned people
find it deeply offensive that you would
want to expand hunter numbers like what
are you talking about why would you do
that
it'd be like when i was in i think when
i was in 8th or 9th grade i had a civics
teacher
no he was in high school i had a civics
teacher who was supposed to help
all of us kids get registered to vote
and he was like why would i want you
people to register to vote
why would i want to dilute my vote
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs the colorful days of fall
are now
upon us are your small businesses needs
evolving changing with the times
certainly true for me and my team and
despite the current uncertainty in the
world having the right people on your
team can wrap you in feelings of
security and peace of mind
like a warm blanket it's never been more
important to find and hire the right
people
linkedin has an active community of
professionals more than 690 million
members worldwide
and when your business is ready to make
that next hire linkedin jobs can help
you find the right person quickly by
matching your role with qualified
candidates
getting started is easier than ever with
new features to help you find
qualified candidates quickly manage job
posts and contact candidates from one
simple view on linkedin.com's
familiar website it's super easy
identify strong candidates with their
efficient rating system
to easily get your job in front of more
qualified professionals
and now you can also do all of this from
your mobile device so when your business
is ready to make that next hire or if
you just want to check it out
find the right person faster with
linkedin jobs you can pay what you want
and get the first fifty dollars off
just visit linkedin.com tim all caps tim
again that's
linkedin.comtim to get 50 off of your
first
job post terms and conditions apply
if we look at the different
extirpated species in portions of the
united states that whole spectrum
are hunters 99 or 100
focused on reintroducing basically
target prey
species or are they also involved in
reintroducing
species i'm not saying necessarily but
you mentioned the grizzly
or or other carnivores who would compete
with them for the game that they
hope to capture themselves
yeah that's where it gets pretty tricky
man i would like to tell you
oh i would love to tell you
that my uh my hunting compatriots
were as supportive of efforts to
recover non-game species
as they were game species but
that's not true
when you look at the habitat work you'll
find that we have these
terms we use like capstone keystone
species okay
and when you look at organizations that
do habitat work
they would tell you and they're right in
telling you this that there is a
massive trickle-down effect for instance
let's look at the work
work by two groups like ducks unlimited
rocky mountain elk found it we'll do
three ducks unlimited rocky mountain elk
foundation
wild turkey federation okay now
you listen to those names we'll throw a
fish in one and two and say trout
unlimited right
you look at those names these are like
species specific
conservation groups and their
constituencies
are hunters and anglers i'm sure there's
probably some person that belongs the
national wild turkey
i'm like a lifetime member of national
turkey federation i'm sure there's
people
belonging to national wild cherokee
federation that don't hunt turkeys but
in the words of pat dirk and i bet they
sleep with someone that does
right what their work winds up focusing
on
is it's not so much that you're managing
the animals though that happened at a
time
at a time like wildlife work in this
country
really was focused pretty heavily on
moving animals around
okay putting them back in places that's
become complicated for a variety of
things including disease transmission
and
other issues just like red tape issues
bureaucratic issues disease transmission
issues that make
you can't just really nearly truck
animals around the country dumping them
out where you wish they were
anymore it's tough these organizations
now mostly focus on habitat work
oftentimes their primary thing is simply
buying and protecting habitat when you
get into something like keystone species
let's say your ducks unlimited
and you take money and you buy
wetlands okay you're looking for
pristine
imperiled wetland habitats
and buy them often through like a
willing seller willing buyer
transaction which is one of the things
also one of the things rocky mountain
elder foundation does in turkey
federation these places all often
do the same playbook they get grants
they raise money from
donors they do fundraisers and a big
part of their work is they identify
keystone habitats for like you know you
hear like keystone species so it's a
thing that they want
it's a thing they like and by securing
habitat
for that animal you're securing habitat
for everything
that that lives there restoring natural
ecosystems
in the west for instance one of the more
imperiled eco types in the west is like
large riparian areas
elk winter in these large riparian areas
meaning they go down along the main
rivers okay
they go down into big river valleys to
get out of the elevation get out of the
snow
and get into good grasslands and eat if
you want to help
elk it used to be the best way to help
elk was tranquilizing them lifting them
up with a helicopter and moving them
over a couple mountain ranges and
letting them back
go again now we recognize like the way
to help elk is to look at like where is
the bottleneck in their well-being
and the bottleneck and their well-being
is often riparian habitat areas so we're
gonna go
and preserve protect as much riparian
habitat as we can
who else uses riparian habitat and who
else likes
a lot of elk well wolves like it in the
winter
wolves need a lot of elk so by helping
elk
through improving their habitat and
protecting their habitat
you're helping everything on the
landscape
from songbirds to insects
pollinators raptors you're helping
everything
people definitely recognize this when
they participate these activities
but the motivation is
that people like elk they like to hunt
elk and they want a shitload of elk
and you can critique their motivation
all you want but then you can't really
you have to then look at like what is
the sum thing the sum part of it is that
a group like rocky mountain elk
foundation or national wild turkey
federation
right they have every year they
add to the net amount
of pristine wildlife habitat that exists
in this country
and you you cannot say the same thing
about peta you can't say it when it
really comes down to
really saving animals that's saving
habitat
the animals you give them the right
place the animals for the most part take
care of themselves
and that's what's being done by hunters
and anglers and i suppose that would and
you know so much more about this but
that would be
in some respect conditional upon letting
the
full spectrum of species flourish that
are supported by this
preservation or conservation of habitat
for say the elk
during the winter periods right so yeah
i forgot i forgot that part yeah there's
a lot of
tremendous animosity there's a
tremendous amount of animosity
toward wolves among in the hunting
community it's definitely not
across the board i know a lot of hunters
that
really like to see wolves and welcome
wolves on the landscape but yeah
i should clarify that when it comes to
i'm speaking very generally here okay
i'm speaking very generally i would say
in general let me put this way let's
take a state that doesn't have wolves
i would say that if someone proposed
reintroducing
wolves in missouri they would get
an enormous amount of pushback from
deer hunters when someone decided to do
reintroduction work in portions of
missouri on turkeys i do not think
they would have gotten any pushback
from hunters so yeah what people
like all predators i look at a little
bit like this you know
when a coyote runs into a red fox he
likes to kill it when a wolf runs into a
coyote
he likes to kill it uh predators tend to
want to reduce their competition and i
think that you could say that about
hunters in general though there are many
many many
exceptions i know some very avid hunters
lifelong very avid hunters who really
welcome
wolves as wolves expand their range
every year
welcome wolves back on the landscape and
even within those people that welcome
back on the landscape
you'll find differences there's a push
right now there's a there's like a
referendum vote in colorado coming right
up to sort of like
mandate the reintroduction of wolves in
colorado a lot of people are uneasy with
that
the reason they're uneasy with that is
wolves are coming in
naturally drifting down from wyoming
it's as nuanced as this you'll have
people say
why would we reintroduce them when
they're showing up at their own pace
through natural migration and that's
like a pretty nuanced perspective right
i welcome them
walking in i don't welcome them flying
in
so it's hard to draw these sort of like
real hard and fast rules about
people's attitudes about it and there's
a real contradiction like like a funny
part of this i'd like to point out to
people
alaska still has wolves and grizzlies
you know i don't know across
99 or 95 percent of their historic range
in alaska
alaska doesn't have large they don't
have large land mammals on the
endangered species act
right they've maintained all their stuff
uh
wolves everywhere you go there's a
likelihood of running into wolves
you're gonna run into grizzlies yet
american hunters all
dream of going up to hunt in alaska and
you always want to point out like are
you sure
i you hate wolves that place is full of
wolves there must have been any game in
alaska
how could there be game in alaska they
have wolves and you would think with
some people that wolves coming back
into certain areas would mean the sure
death of all ungulates that live there
and i think that's an exaggeration but
wolves don't eat granola bars either you
know they eat seven pounds of meat a day
seven pounds of meat a day they're alive
365 days a year
they kill a lot of [ __ ] and to say like
how
hunters think about it is really tough
man because it's
the full array of thoughts but i'll say
this
we don't like those wolves as much as we
like those elk
and that's that i can promise you is
true
yeah the the wolf conversation remember
somebody put it to me
as a wolf well wolves in general are the
middle east of conservation
he said if you want really really
strong emotions and a lot of polarity
then that is the right place to focus
there's a
really good piece in the new yorker
there's a profile
on i think it's karen vardaman called
the persuasive power of the wolf lady
which is about a
go-between between these these two polar
extremes and you actually
had i had a someone named mike phillips
i don't know if you know that name
who's in montana but was involved with
the yellowstone wolf
reintroduction oh yeah yeah and you had
a scientist also on your podcast
that was outstanding that was a that was
a really
really really dense and also
entertaining
episode so for people who want to to dig
into that and i think dave meach
is that another am i getting that right
m-a-c-h i'm not i think i'm pronouncing
that correctly he's also somebody if
people want to learn more about this
he's another person who
who focuses quite heavily on the the
wolf component
yeah colorado is faced with a very
similar situation
that is what montana was faced with when
they did a reintroduction in you know
essentially in wyoming you know in
yellowstone national park
is that there were animals coming in
naturally
there were animals coming in naturally
from canada we would have landed
eventually
where in the future from today we would
have
landed where we are now without doing
the reintroduction
and some people would say the same thing
about colorado
they're headed that direction there are
wolves showing up it used to be like
a rumor it was debated it's just an
absolute fact now like there are wolves
in colorado
uh coming in on their own and some
people
prefer that because the social tensions
become lower there's a thing that can
happen with animals
you might call it the spotted owl
effication
of certain species where when
conservation becomes so partisan and so
political
oftentimes an animosity toward the
animal develops
because the animal becomes emblematic of
what some people might
view as federal overreach right and like
something being shoved down their
throats
and so politically and culturally
it seems that it's a little safer to let
things happen
gradually and naturally than it is to
force your hand
by politicizing biology
it seems super super tricky right
because you have
so many subtleties here and like you
said whether it's
face masks or spotted owl or wolves once
things become
politically associated whether by
just circumstance and momentum or by
some kind of
engineering on one side or both sides
for voting purposes
it complicates matters a lot and then i
would also that's
it's really interesting to you that you
i love that
the mention of face masks where yeah
you're right we're not talking about
face masks yeah we're not talking about
facebook
it's like it's we're not actually
talking about the thing on your face
we're talking about like this whole set
of ideas associated with the thing right
yeah that's a good point
exactly exactly and humans are motivated
right so
you really have to take into
consideration the motivations
of whoever is speaking whether they are
hunters non-hunters
or anyone with incentives in the world
right and
because there are people who would say
and we don't have to spend a ton of time
on this but
that wolves were so forcefully
removed i don't want to apply the word
artificial but they were certainly
with overwhelming sort of show of force
and poison
they were removed with intent yeah with
interest
with like specific specific stated
intent elk
were removed not with a
they were removed not with specific
intent no one set out to be like i would
like to remove elk from the landscape it
just happened right
right yeah wolves were like no it was a
plan there was a bounty there was poison
there was a plan and the plan worked too
well yeah
yeah so if anybody wants to wait into
the middle east of conservation that's a
good place to do it uh
friendships end over wolves man yeah it
is a tense conversation for a lot of
folks
you mentioned alaska i want to talk
about alaska and i i want to give a
slice of life uh mini profile
of steve ronella so this this is going
to be another flashback moment and for
those interested we this is captured
on footage but i'm not sure all of it is
captured so
you and i traveled up to alaska at one
point
and ended up fair to say pretty much in
the middle of nowhere i mean one of the
most remote points
in north america got grounded for
weather for a while and
it was just an incredible adventure and
we had at one point actually at more
than one point but at least at one point
on camera we had a grizzly
a barren ground grizzly which you could
explain run into our camp
and the reason i bring up that is
a that was something i'd never
experienced before and
uh i and other members of the film crew
were like
steve what do we do steve what do we do
and this bear was
running around this body of water
straight towards camp
and i don't know how far away it was
let's call it half mile
you can correct me but let's just say a
half mile which is not very far
and meanwhile you had just gotten out of
your tent
this is the part that i don't know if
it's on camera or not you've just gotten
out of your tent
and i don't know if you remember this a
bunch of mosquito repellent yeah had
spilled and you understand 100
deep had spilled and eaten a hole
through the floor of my tent
and warped my phone case and ruined my
phone
so so you get up and you're like god
damn it
a whole [ __ ] a whole 3x10 and that's
the stuff we wear on our skin
right so you are so you're just like
stamping around
furious cursing at while this bear is
is running around this body of water and
uh everyone's like steve
um steve what do you want to do here
steve say steve and you're like god damn
it [ __ ] so
angry and eventually they're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you like grab a
shotgun and shoot in the air and wave
your hands and
spook this bear which was a pretty large
grizzly bear you could speak to it at
least
from my perspective certainly a lot
bigger than my dog ran like
a quarter mile away kind of sat down and
looked at us and just
kind of waited uh but could you could
you
maybe add some color to that story
because it certainly
burned and etched the experience
indelibly into my mind
but what are what are some of the
details that i'm missing here yeah
you're right about the deep
the bottle 100 percent deet and man it
want to ruin a lot of my stuff because
it had
given i had given it a lot of time to
fester spilled in the corner of my tent
and leaked out it like
it was a mess in terms of the barrier so
i'll point this out
we've been talking about grizzly bears i
mean we've touched on grizzly bears in
the lower 48.
anytime we use the word grizzly bear if
you ask a taxonomist like a geneticist
they would tell you that grizzly bears
in the lower 48
brown what we call brown bears kodiak
bears
baron ground grizzlies up on the arctic
slope where we were up in the brooks
range
it's all the same species right so they
have big differences physiological
differences they look different they act
different in these different places but
it's just different
you know kind of like manifestations of
the same animal and
one of the things that these barren
ground grizzlies up there
or uh you know bears in the interior the
thing they're known for is they have
these enormous home ranges
a brown bear let's say a kodiak brown
bear everybody's heard of that like
biggest bears in the world
biggest you know brown bears in the
world they might have a very very small
home range
they eat a lot of salmon they live in a
resource-rich environment
they got their spot and they they stay
there and defend it against other bores
but up in these areas uh
you have it's a i hate states i don't
want people to take it the wrong way
up in the like the arctic slope and in
the brooks range it's a it's a resource
poor area it looks amazing
it's gorgeous when you're out in front
of a migrating herd of caribou
it looks like the land is like crawling
with animals
but the thing is you could sit there at
times of the year
you could sit there for months and
nothing will come by
and so a big animal like that
just covers ground and they need to be
extraordinarily opportunistic
they're going to be eating primarily
probably the bulk of that animal's diet
is going to be vegetation
berries roots but they're just
on the move all the time because they're
always out looking for like that big
windfall
a big hit like a big protein hit and so
they cover ground
and they have an amazing nose on them i
one time was caribou hunting in a
different area
east of where you and i were and we had
gone
three miles up a tributary to a river
and
killed a caribou and gutted it and
hauled the meat back down to the main
stem
that night we were sitting on the main
branch of the river at the mouth of that
tributary and watch the grizzly coming
down
digging up roots in the gravel bar and
it got to the mouth of that tributary
and you could see something strike its
nose to wear like a scent and it stood
up on its back legs
waved its nose in the air for a long
time spun around did it again
and eventually ran up that tributary
and i didn't go check but i i am certain
based on the wind patterns that he
smelled that gut pile from three miles
away
and that's what they're out doing man
they're covering ground and so
on that trip we were on we had i don't
know
at the time one or two caribou on the
ground
and there's no trees there you know it's
it's a barren land you know
a treeless environment and the trees
that are there are shrubby and doesn't
do any good meaning
you can't hang it up in a tree to keep
it safe so if you have a cache of meat
that you're trying to protect the best
thing is to put it where you can keep an
eye on it
like close to camp if you move it away a
mile it's just going to get you know
consumed and you won't even you won't be
able to protect it you won't even know
that it happened
if you put it right in your camp you're
inviting stuff to come right in your
camp so you just kind of put it
off or you can keep an eye on it 75
yards away 100 yards away depending on
what's going on and this bear comes
along
to claim that caribou uh he's probably
done that a ton of times he comes in
and probably has in his life countless
times fought off other bears to claim a
dead caribou fought off wolves
to claim their caribou uh in that place
too it's very likely
that that animal had never had a direct
experience with a human before
seize aircraft right whatever maybe
smelled people somewhere but probably
never had direct experience
it's just knowing that it's cruising
along and probably had miles away
long before we knew it was there had
smelled that animal and was coming
to get it and then it gets there and
you present to it in a way that's kind
of like authoritatively saying
this is already mine this thing is
claimed
you have no right to be here like that's
what you're trying to
express to that animal and sometimes it
works and sometimes it doesn't work
i got a lot of friends you know people
lose stuff to those things all the time
but in that case
that little show of force like i'm not
afraid of you uh this is
my [ __ ] does not your [ __ ] worked and he
it ran off and then surprisingly didn't
come back in the dark and try again
well i remember going to bed that night
and it was just
like you know we're in these skin thin
single person tents and uh i was saying
to
uh i'm half blanket on his name was it
nick his neck who's
yeah nick yeah nick was with us and i
was like well
hope you don't die tonight and he was
like you too man
[Laughter]
oh yeah because they can have a real
attitude about claiming stuff man
you know claiming to kill and people get
every year
it's kind of amazing to think you know
every year in the lower 48 you know
multiple people get killed most every
year from
grizzly bears this is going to sound
callous but you know
that that could happen is is like i hold
that risk is kind of cool
i like it like i don't mind there being
something
big and scary like that out there in
fact i drive a lot of
emotional satisfaction from it and this
is beyond any sense that
that i don't like it when humans play
god and decide to
remove animals from the landscape but
just i just i
like that i feel more alive better
more engaged happier in places that have
that full suite
of large predators omnivores you know
out on the landscape so i relish those
interactions
and i also am aware that you know at
some point in time i'm part of a
very high risk group around bears and i
don't think
something will happen to me but i'm part
of a high-risk group and it's like i'll
feel lucky if i get out of life without
having someone i'm very close to get
mauled by a bear
or killed in a small airplane crash you
know it's just like things i recognize
is like those are
re actual those are actual real threats
people
fixate on the wrong things when they
imagine danger
but if you spend a lot of time hunting
in these areas that's not a fantasy
that you could get mixed up with a bear
it strikes me that if we're talking
about for instance the
bear attacks uh which are so
visually memorable for anyone who's seen
the revenant for instance
they're gonna they're gonna have a movie
they can play in their mind of what a
bear attack
looks like where a small plane crash may
just be off menu they just don't have a
reference for it but that's great we
definitely don't have one for
hypothermia
yeah we don't have one no one goes in
the woods being like dude i hope i don't
die of hypothermia
but i'm like you know what that's like
i'd be watching out for that
yeah it's not it's cinematically
compelling but it sure will kill you
just as well
and are you more afraid because you you
take a lot of
small aircraft i would imagine i mean
certainly we did we took these
you know bush planes these are tiny tiny
aircraft and you are not landing on
a perfectly manicured asphalt
at all times right and do you worry more
about
the aircraft or in this case bears
predators the thing about the aircraft
is like there's a sort of statistical
bit of it right like you can look you go
to a place like alaska where it's like
it's a primary mode of transportation
like in most places like having a
private single-engine plane is a
hobbyist right or like a flying
enthusiast you know
oftentimes flying for the sake of flying
you're a place like alaska and much of
canada
you know it's like that's like how you
get around right right um it's it's like
how you do it i remember
it was uh it was ted stevens in alaska
i think it was him that he talked about
an occupational hazard of
politics in that state was small
aircraft
and then died in one but you can look at
like hours you know like crashes per
hour or whatever so
someone like me no i don't have any real
reason to worry about it i have a
brother who's a
who's an ecologist in alaska and
he spends a lot of time in single-engine
aircraft a lot of time in
you know fixed-wing and helicopters and
yeah man
you get to a point where all those
people that do that
they all know people right they
all know people that that's happened to
i've to the point now where
like you know i've been in planes
that i later knew crashed uh
that's spooky yeah but it's like for me
it's just so minor like you know
you know some number of trips a year but
the people i know like especially people
in the
in the fish and wildlife the who do fish
and wildlife work
up there i do worry man i do worry like
my brother spends a lot of time in those
things and i worry about that
but for me if you're at least open to
thinking statistically
personally i have no reason to be
concerned well for people who want to
get a glimpse
of alaska you can certainly read some
amazing books like coming into the
country yeah by john mcphee but if you
want a visual
sampler i just pulled this up i don't
know if this is accurate because it's on
imdb
it could be it says season three episode
one of
meat eaters that sounds like it is is
our episode
where uh we travel to the remotest
corner of alaska to catch the annual
migration of the famed western arctic
caribou herd
can people find where can people find if
they can
these these older episodes you can find
all the older episodes
if you go to themeeter.com and you'll
go there and you'll find you'll you'll
find your avenue to all the older
episodes okay great yeah
it looks like the episode is called true
north alaska north slope caribou
season three episode one we'll put that
in the show notes also guys yeah those
are all awesome
they're also available in our broadcast
by
sportsman channel you know like outdoor
channel and sportsman channel
but then you can also find them by going
to themeeater.com they're not available
on netflix
we're going to be doing some things soon
around distribution with some of our
older material but that's where you can
find them right now
perfect let's move from television to
books and in this case books that are
not yours we can certainly spend
more time on books that are yours but i
read that you recommend
and i don't know how old this interview
was a few books
very commonly son of the morning star by
evan s connell arctic dreams by barry
lopez and boone by daniel morgan
do you still or would you still
recommend those what's special about
these books
son of the morning star is
about the events
leading up to and including the
battle at the little bighorn where
custer's last stand it's a great story i
mean it's just like a story that just
makes its own gravy
it's just incredible the brutality
and just just weirdness of
that campaign the culmination of
custer's involvement in that campaign
one of the things i love most about it
besides just like phenomenal reporting
is the openness with which the author
approaches how different people remember
things
and reading it you get a a sense of how
there are at any given time you know and
this is just so
applicable today there are a hundred
truths i don't mean 100 like one zero
zero
there are as many truths as there are
people
about what went on during something
and his exploration of people's accounts
of what happened
that day and the days surrounding it
when custer died
and who did what and who was where and
who thought what and
uh what was going on it's just the
question marks that loom over that stuff
are
unbelievable it's a great telling it's a
great piece about just like human memory
but also a phenomenal history of the
american west in the phenomenal history
of the indian wars
to say like what led up to the battle
little bighorn
you can approach that in a hundred ways
man you can take a 500 year approach
right
you could take a a a decade approach
you could take a week-long approach and
he kind of manages
to sort of like cover off on all those
ways to lead up to
how in the world did a couple hundred
us soldiers get wiped
out killed off by planes indians
armed with antiquated firearms and bows
and arrows
in to quote one of the sioux
participants in the battle named gaul
in the amount of time that it takes a
hungry man to eat his dinner
it's just so bizarre um
it's just candy like it's it's history
candy
and he's such a great he's just great i
feel it like a western literature
masterpiece
arctic dreams um is a work of natural
history
uh arctic dreams is a book about the
arctic one of the most profound parts
about it for me
is that the author barry lopez is very
uneasy with hunting
i would venture to say that barry lopez
would probably not like me too much
but what would he what would he dislike
about you it's just very uneasy with
hunting
got it he's only you know if you re he's
uneasy with hunting
he spends a lot of time with indigenous
hunters in the arctic
so he spends a lot of time with eskimo
inuit hunters
and he is at peace he's relatively at
peace with that though he recognizes the
violence
but he's at peace with that indigenous
approach to hunting you would look at
that and
i find that's often quite true people
who uh would be like they don't want
violence toward animals
right but they're very accepting if it's
done by an indigenous person
as though the animal somehow feels that
pain differently
you can't really ignore that if you're a
walrus getting shot in the head
on the ice flow i don't know that you
care
who's pulling the trigger right
i really don't think that that is of
issue to them but people are tend to be
much more comfortable with that
and uh he gets into it and arctic dreams
also just it's someone trying to
comprehend an incomprehensible landscape
tim i love you remember being out there
on the in the arctic there
do you remember the tussocks oh well i
was going to you know i was going to
bring those up because you mentioned the
lack of trees
i was going to make t-shirts for
everybody if you remember that
i love tussocks yeah because those
[ __ ] ankle breakers man you gotta
i mean they're you you can describe them
they're like one-third inflated
volleyballs covered with
[ __ ] dog hair i mean yeah they're
like the most dangerous things you can
think of and it's just like
many many hundreds of square miles of
these things yeah and you can't decide
if you're going to try walking between
the tossings or on the tussocks and the
toxics are you know they might be
like 12 inches 18 inches tall and they
flop around
i was liking it too if you filled a gym
full of
six inches of water and then took
basketballs
and somehow like tethered them to the
floor
so that all the basketballs are touching
and then tried to walk across and then
you'd be like you got to go across there
for a few miles
and then you might figure out some way
to walk on those basketballs i don't
know
or you might find some way to get your
feet wedged down between those
basketballs but either way
like i invite you to do this little
journey uh but in arctic dreams one of
the best parts arctic dreams is how
about a
botanist whose spends their day
face down on a tussock counting
doing a survey on that tussock of the
vegetation on that tussock
and the thousands of blades of you know
sedges and
forbs and right and just trying to
comprehend like
what's going on in this tussock all
these plant species
right incredibly dense
and then having this feeling of like
doing that and then looking up
and any direction you can look as far as
the eye can see
it's just more and more and more of
those tussocks right it's just like an
incomprehensible landscape and that book
does a wonderful job of spelling that
out
and it does a wonderful job of like
challenging some things
um of challenging some things and
challenging some assumptions
and that book won the national book
award yeah i was just
looking it up it's funny that's that's
that's no joke
just as a just as a side note uh i still
want to hear about boone
but the i think perhaps the most
nervous that i was at any point in that
trip
in the uh brooks range was
well if i'm being honest it was probably
the the grizzly bear
acutely but nothing happened but when i
had a lot of time to meditate on the
dozens of ways that i could like
fracture a leg or dislocate a hip and
really be [ __ ] because you know how
hard it is to get to this place and it's
not like you just
call someone on a cell phone and you
know an uber helicopter shows up in five
minutes like you could be stuck there
for a very long time
oh yeah weather depending you'd be there
days
yeah so when we were packing out the
meat from the caribou hunt
and so imagine you're in this this gym
that you visualized earlier right with
the six inches of water with all the
basketballs touching and tethered to the
floor and you have to walk across that
and then take a backpack with i don't
know you tell me i'm not i don't recall
what percentage of the body weight
of a caribou would end up being
harvestable meat
but i don't know what 60 to 100 pounds
on each person's back maybe
something like that oh yeah yeah you
know you'd have a total of them
you know over a couple you know a couple
hundred pounds
potentially well that might be a bit
much but yeah you'd be
with with the bones in there you're
moving
you're moving a couple hundred pounds
for sure plus right
yeah so that's important yeah impacts
ranging like at 50 pounds a backpack is
substantial it decreases your mobility
at 90 and 100 pounds a backpack is
you're like wow this is sort of uh you
need to step carefully like you're like
you could hurt yourself carrying this
weight like it's not yet for you to
carry this weight
and i remember you know you commenting
that if there were a sport that just
involved
carrying heavy weights for long
distances that you could be
you know the one sport i'd be good at
and in my case it's like when's the last
time that i walked on
half inflated volleyballs for a mile
with
a hundred pounds or 80 pounds on my back
and the answer is never and i was like
wow like okay my
like glute medius and all these
stabilizers in the hip
have no training for this whatsoever so
thank god there are people like uh dan
dodie and other monsters
uh behind the cameras are like yeah let
me just grab that for you i'm like
okay hurts my masculine pride a bit but
i'm uh
less interested in fracturing both my
legs so i'll take the help
thank you very much trained tussock
walkers
so boone by daniel morgan yeah i've had
a lifelong
fascination with boone and uh any little
kid that grows up
loving to hunt and trap and fish and
stuff like you're aware of boone right
you're aware of this pioneer boon
and at various times in history he was
remembered as you know an indian fighter
right
even though he never he didn't really
have a big
appetite for that and if you look at
what he did he actually
went out of his way typically went out
of his way to avoid violence
but an indian fighter a pioneer an
explorer hunter trapper
and you know at various times my life
i've been in love with different aspects
of what he did
but and he often in old books
you know he was kind of presented as
this swashbuckling
you know davey crockett figure right
whistling through the woods
just being a hero but there's a lot of
complexity there
around this person and sort of this idea
that he
was heavily involved in destroying
what it was that he loved he made his
money in a variety of ways and he was a
horrible
had made a lot of business mistakes a
lot of land mistakes and different
investments and stuff but like for the
most of his life he was a commercial
hunter and he was a trespasser so he was
hunting places
one that had native americans that
claimed it and lived on it and they
fought amongst themselves over ownership
of these hunting grounds but there was
that
which meant you know next to nothing to
him and then there was the fact that he
was
trespassing on land that he wasn't
supposed to come on from his own
government
um in the time of the colonies the we
were always striking these deals
where we would assure the tribes like oh
no this is about it we're not going to
go any more west
we promise our settlers won't go over
that line and the rest that's yours
we'll take this and and boone didn't
care about that stuff at all either
he just went where he wanted to go um
and we now like do this we describe this
as a sort of celebration of freedom
but it'd be uh if you took that attitude
a day you would be called an interloper
and a poacher and you'd wind up in jail
but
he was pursuing his trade he hunted deer
for leather
not not so much meat they hunted deer
for leather leather work wear
um it was sold and tanned and they made
like the equivalent of making carharts
today
he did that for a lot of the year and
then he hunted bears for the
oil and meat markets he would go out
kill bears
smoke the meat render the fat sell the
smoked meat
bear bacon and sell the bear oil and
that's how this guy made his living
the book does a great telling of all
this stuff but a thing that i love about
boone and i've come to respect about
boone is
he exemplifies this part of my
history as a hunter when i say my
history i don't mean the things that
happened in my life but as a
continuation
of a sort of discipline as a
continuation of hunting in america he's
this really pinnacle moment where
you have this person that loved
wilderness
loved the outdoors risked his neck day
to day to go to the wildest places and
celebrate them and he
liked those places he wanted to be there
boone would sometimes
go on a hunt that would last two years
gone from his wife and family for two
years hunting
and lost all the hides he built up twice
by having them
confiscated by native americans who
resented his trespassing he
liked it he could have found a hundred
other ways to make a living that was
what he was he was a woodsman
but he was one of these guys in our own
history
who was instrumental
in wiping wildlife off the face of
america
and it's this part of this conundrum
we're in where
we look and i'm like that i i celebrate
that guy
right his skill set you can't begin to
comprehend his skill set all the [ __ ]
they did they did without flashlights
it's like you can't begin to comprehend
the skill set
and admire and like if i could go back
in time my number one pick
would be to go through the cumberland
gap with daniel boone the first time he
went through the cumberland gap and
crossed down into the
hunting grounds of kentucky to do that
walk with him
but my god the damage like the damage
no no was the damage his influence or
was it just the
manner in which that he hunted and what
he represented
being done on a wider scale what was the
damage both
influence by opening up those places it
would have happened anyways
someone else would have done it by
opening up settlement opening up
clearing the road for the displacement
of
indigenous people clearing the road for
people who would destroy the habitat
but also just the mechanical physical
removal of all that wildlife
he one time processed uh i think it's
right around us i think this is correct
i think one time he processed 109 black
bears in a year
that's a lot of bears oh listen they
wiped them we talked about extra patient
earlier
they were wiping out stuff without even
knowing they'd wiped it out there used
to be bison in nashville there's a guy
that saw a thousand
bison at a mineral lick near nashville
one time people came into new orleans
and saw bison they were on the beach
it seems as though people ran into near
washington dc
these guys shot stuff they shot stuff so
fast and so thoroughly that the ship was
gone and he didn't know it was gone
yeah that's incredible we now sit around
people we sit around now like the last
bear of
you know he killed the last bear in
indiana or whatever you know it's like
it's like a thing people used to kind of
celebrate celebrated i mean they were
just rapacious
but they had no compre i don't think
they had any comprehension of what they
were doing there's a story i like to
tell a lot about
with with bison there's a story like
tell a lot about the hyde hunters that
can i pause you for one second
just to establish your bona fides so i'm
looking at
one of your many books and this one is
american buffalo in search of a lost
icon
1213 reviews average
five stars so you you you've done a lot
of reading
and research related to this please
continue oh yeah i i knew that world
real well back when i was working on
that book but there's a great story
about like what
the damage that hunters do without
knowing they've done it is
you know so i'm going to just throw some
wild round numbers out like at the end
of the civil war
it's estimated there are maybe about 15
million buffalo
bison on the great plains right and
we were hunting them for their tongues
meat but mostly we hunt them for their
heights there was a there's a strong
market for leather and hides
and we had a lot of market hunters
chasing after them so the civil war ends
people say there's maybe about 15
million we really turn our attention
west we start cutting railroads
we open up avenues of trade meaning you
can you could kill buffalo and stick the
hides on rail cars and send them to
market
we had we were feeding an industrial
revolution and so p there's a lot of
money to be made shooting hides
and they kind of killed off the ones in
the south from the texas plains kansas
right and then they started working on
the northern herds and
some people say that that by the time
the northern pacific railroad
made it into had crossed the western
dakotas made it into eastern montana
there was maybe a couple million left in
the last wild herd
and they shot that herd out in the
winter at 81 82
1881 1882 gone right a couple years
later this guy horn today william t
hornaday goes out there to collect
specimens for the smithsonian like the
assumption is they'll just be gone
they'll be exterminated
extinct and he wants to collect some
hides and bones and stuff so that man in
the future will be able to behold what
these things looked like before they
were
driven to extinction and he comments
when he gets out to mile city he
comments how the people that live around
mile city the ranchers
the merchants were people that had been
involved in that last big slaughter
and then they were just hanging around
waiting for the next herd to come
through
everybody knew there must be a bunch
more up north or somewhere
and they waited and a year goes by and
none came
and they waited and two years goes by
and none came
and eventually they kind of got like huh
and set up
various businesses and ranching
operations and gradually occurred to
them that like
oh [ __ ] we got them all accidentally
right it's like
so when you look at these people like
getting back to this boon thing which is
the question
when you look at these people that were
engaged in this stuff like i don't think
they
they knew they knew that something was
amiss and they knew that like things
were changing because that's why boone
had to constantly move pennsylvania to
north carolina he constantly marched
west by the time he died it's rumored
that he had made it all the way up into
the rockies following the missouri river
up on a hunting trip
he always had to move west because they
killed everything and it forced him to
need to move he was aware of this
but i don't know that they really were
like
villains i don't know they really were
acting with malicious intent but my god
really destructive
and also just cool it's like
it's a good book it's it's the best
piece of work about boone
well these are all amazing stories your
story is pretty
incredible and wanna rewind to
your first sold piece of writing so
you mentioned this in passing we didn't
get really into it but
your plan a was to be a professional fur
trapper up until
something like 22 right i had to give up
yeah you had to give up uh for a whole
host of reasons
and you decide that plan b was
to become an outdoor writer so your your
first story
sold in 2000 to outside is that right
yeah something
that was the first like piece i like
sold for money
what was that piece about that you
remember oh i do
i i i'm still mad about the title um
you don't get to pick your own title
they called my article
getting jiggy
[Music]
which i'm still mad about it
20 years later i love dearly i love
dearly and i'm still friends with the
person who oversaw that process i've
never told her about my
my anger but it was about so for a while
for a semester
when i was younger i was young in
michigan and everyone if you hunted and
fished
you know where you needed to go live was
what we called the up that was like the
cool spot and so
some of my closest friends my brothers
they like went up to the u.p to go to
college
up upper peninsula michigan yeah so it
was just like kind of like the
the promised land you know or that's how
we viewed it anyway
and i went up there to live for a
semester at lake superior state
university my brother danny he stayed up
there and graduated from there so i was
in and out of there all the time and
there was this hydroelectric
diversion canal in lake superior where
they peel water off the saint mary's
river
and run it through a channel and run it
through a hydroelectric dam
right so just turn turbines to make
electricity and uh
this canal had a lot of aquatic insects
that lived in it and so
fish would gather at the out wash of
this dam so where they release the water
out after passing through the turbines
they release this water back into the
saint mary's river
and it would carry with it a lot of food
and you'd go up and like we would
actually
tie our boats up to the dam and you're
just fishing for whitefish
lake superior great lakes whitefish
you're fishing for whitefish in the
outwash of the dam and we would
sometimes my brothers had
figured this out you could leave the bar
it was competitive to get the right
tunnel
the right turbines that seemed to hold a
lot of fish for whatever reason i never
understood certain turbines held a lot
of fish
no matter how early you got up you know
some dude had beat you some old-timer
beating to the spot so my brothers hit
on this idea just to leave the bar
at one or two in the morning whatever
and go out with a sleeping bag
okay i was sleeping there was a
technical term you mean the bar
oh no it'd be like well screw we're
getting up at five let's just sleep
there
so i would go out with my brother danny
and and uh
they'd run we'd run a boat up in and
we'd go
in the tunnel like you're like you're in
the bowels of the dam because it's warm
in there
from the turbine and there's these like
little hooks in there and you could
drive your boat
into the tunnel and tie off and just
like sleep in a sleeping bag
and then at five in the morning when
some old you know some old-timer fishing
fanatic shows up
lo and behold you know you're laying
there hung over in the sleeping bag
ready to fish and i i wrote a piece
about this
oh you know what i was wrong earlier
that wasn't the one they called getting
jiggy i was mistaken about that that was
called dawn patrol
again jake was a was another article i
wrote about something very similar in
seattle i'm sorry i was
i screwed that up dawn patrol and i
still i was still in graduate school and
sold i remember for four thousand bucks
and i couldn't imagine that amount of
money
it was like an unfathomable amount of
money
we partied for days after that were you
always
a an able writer or did you do something
between
i guess 22 or whenever you
begin thinking about outdoor writer as
an option what enabled you to
get to that point because i am not a
features writer or magazine writer so
it's hard for me to
i don't it's hard for me to speculate in
that world but i wouldn't imagine that
most
folks start off with a four thousand
dollar
payment for a magazine piece they're
probably doing bit small stuff here or
there
oh i did all that small work after that
you know it took a long time
i got encouragement you know it's so
hard like pick out like what exact
moment turned it but
but absolutely this this goes out to all
the school teachers out there
when i was in 10th grade i had a english
teacher named
bob heaton mr heaton took interest in me
as a writer you know i later went to i
did a you know master of fine arts right
i did all i studied with phenomenal
writers i've had many mentors
i've had people pull strings for me i've
had great advantages
right expert technical training all this
stuff
it's really hard to talk about how you
got somewhere where you are but i
feel as though if mr heaton if this 10th
grade english teacher
hadn't spotted something there and and
made me aware of it that i probably
wouldn't have done what i did
i think that's pretty fair to say he
this is kind of interesting around this
i don't know if you're how much you pay
attention to
you know like the education system today
but there's this thing where like we're
more and more into like grooming kids
for
this fear that we're more and more into
grooming kids for standardized testing
and like
i guess at that time mr heaton really
give it he didn't give a [ __ ]
about he didn't give a [ __ ] about
whether you're like you're like doing
the assignments i mean if you were a
slacker or weren't trying he wanted you
to do the assignments
you know but this guy gave a lot of room
if he saw something you liked he just
gave you a lot of room
to like focus in and explore this sounds
like a lot for 10th grade english
except you go there for an hour a day
and half the time you're not paying
attention
but in that time in a couple classes i
took with him after
in that time he like he he took the time
to develop things in kids
and and maybe took the time to develop
things in kids who otherwise didn't have
a lot of prospects
and that's what led me onto the path and
it's been like wild because
you know going in i want to be a writer
and and
kind of backed into doing television and
backed into doing a podcast and now
helping to run a a an outdoor media
company
but yeah man maybe it boils down to that
and the trapping thing is i started i've
set my first trap with my brothers in
1984
and there had been these insanely high
fur prices since 1978
through 1982 and people were making a
bunch of money trapping
muskrats and stuff i came in at the tail
end of that and fur prices just went
down down down
but in the beginning of that i thought
that i would that's what i would do for
a living
now you've expanded quite a lot as you
mentioned
beyond the writing uh before we
leave the world of writing if you are
teaching a class and for all i know
maybe you have but if you were
teaching a class not an english class
but a writing class
specifically could be to 10th graders
could be to freshman in college it
doesn't really matter but i would say
it could be mfa but by that point people
have already kind of decided and honed
some of their skills so
probably let's just call it 10th grade
through to end of college you could pick
the age
what would you do what would your
approach look like are there any
core books or practices or anything that
you would you would use in your class
yeah i'm not gonna do the 10th grade one
but i'll do the college one grad school
one
i just don't have the expertise to uh
it's hard for me to understand 10th
graders even though i you know once upon
a time was one i i understand khalid
like i i'm more aware of where
i was just more cognizant by then if i
was gonna like just writers in general
like writing in general
if i was gonna give advice to someone
this is gonna i don't know if anyone
else gives this advice this way
i would read everything you can get your
hands on
i would pay a lot of attention to the
things that you read that really speak
to you that make you feel jealous
that you wish you would have wrote it i
see you got jealous of the writing
itself
you're like my god if i could do that
right pay attention to the things that
make you feel
like like you want to die it's so good
and you're so jealous find that handful
of writers that that make you feel that
way
try to understand what they're doing and
then don't try to mimic one of them
but create a way in which you're trying
to mimic or you're trying to capture
the thing that you envy about three or
four different writers
because they're too smart to be emulated
you can't copy them
they're geniuses in trying to copy them
you will if you're lucky and you're good
you will come up with something new
because you will never succeed in
copying them
that would be my advice to writers take
it that's what i did
outside of the books that we already
talked about is there a particular
writer who inspires that jesus if i
could just do that
oh for me and you yeah yeah joan didion
this is i'm dating myself because these
are the books that were cool when i was
in graduate school
joan didion ian frazier john mcphee
and david foster wallace that's good
those are the people those are the
people that were like
if i could do that i would be happy
like those are the magicians black magic
[ __ ] man
yeah black magic yeah there's like i
don't know how they do what they do
yeah yeah they're definitely those
experiences i've been having
those experiences in fiction quite a bit
even though i'm not a fiction writer
but it's funny when i talk to i don't i
don't know if
i don't know if you've written fiction i
have not ever
and i've i've spoken to some very
competent fiction writers who've been
like oh non-fiction is too hard and i'm
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
like not good non-fiction is hard don't
get me wrong like to do anything really
well
takes dedication and some degree of
talent i suppose but
when i read really good fiction i'm like
yeah no i can't do that
yeah it's that that's art there's that
like that's art
it leans in the direction of art and i
think non-fiction
leans in the direction of craft yeah
yeah i agree with that
we were talking about season three
episode one you
have season nine of meat ear that just
launched
and you have all these different
projects but if we're looking at
meat eater the television show you've
more than 100 episodes now
are there any particular episodes that
really
stick out for you any particular trips
that are favorites
it could be the film or experience and
maybe that's a lazy question but i'll
throw it out there anyway
they're different what we do is isn't
overly produced and so there's a huge
amount of
a lot of it you just can't produce
because you can't be like the animal
shows up now you know
they're not overly produced which means
that there's like an actual trip
happening there's an actual journey
happening with a question mark around it
since it's not scripted it's like so
there can be the actual journey
you know the trip you the physical trip
you go on and then there's this like
this product that comes out of it
this piece of work this this craft that
comes out of it which is the show
you could have a trip that isn't like
hugely impactful
but the thing you make from it the piece
of entertainment that you make from it
is like memorable you love it you know
you're like man
like i want to have that if in the
future tombstones have like something
playing on tombstones instead of
just inscriptions i would like i would
like my tombstone to play that episode
over and over again
right but it doesn't mean that the trip
was great i think the the things i've
done
the trips i've been on that were like
phenomenal trips and in my view
great episodes were the handful of times
a couple times when we've been able to
go
travel on rivers and hunt and fish
with amerindians in south america
particularly in guyana in bolivia
hunting with people who
are ancestral hunters and gatherers who
are
on a landscape hunting and fishing on a
landscape
that from their view is that they've
been hunting and fishing in perpetuity
probably for thousands of years father
grandfather
on down the line and the level of
intimacy they have
with the land and water where they have
been raised
and where they hunt and fish 200 250
days a year
to see that is a very eye-opening
it's an eye-opening experience because
it really invites you to imagine
what was lost here where we live
in terms of this continuity
that there's still places there where
indigenous
peoples even though there's technologies
emerging and stuff happening all the
time and
and people can have email addresses
where there's like a continuity of like
the same people the same culture
doing the same practices in the same
place
for hundreds or thousands of years a
level of awareness
and like fine-tuned thinking comes out
of that
which is like stunning to witness and
then just the cool [ __ ] like just the
how they cook and
and and uh hunting practices fishing
practices
that's been things that have really
impacted my world view
episodes that doing them impacted my
world view
and then also the delivery of the
product the thing that people go watch
when they're sitting on their living
room couch at night
is in my mind like good work like we did
good work when we did those shows
you mentioned the awareness are there
any particular sensitivities
or types of awareness any examples that
you could give where
you just thought to yourself oh wow
that's something i haven't seen before
that's something i haven't felt before
do any snapshots
come to mind yeah spending time with
these people tracking
okay like detecting sign on the ground
footprints broken blades of grass bent
things just like
animals passing through and knowing that
they pass through
an awareness of bird sound in a place
where
it just feels like a cacophony have you
ever watched that movie about the making
of
herzog's fitzgeraldo movie but you know
that is so strange that you're bringing
this up the burden of dreams yeah
i just started watching it last night
that's bizarre that's super bizarre and
that's not i mean this is not a movie
that
you hear no it's not widely spoken no
one knows so yes
but i literally just started watching it
less than 12 hours you get to a point
where he
is very sick of the jungle and he's
explaining that birds don't sing
they scream in agony
it's this incredible cacophony sometimes
there's just
noise and that they could like sit there
and
dissect that you know it's this bug
it's this it's this it's this is that
bird just that bird does that bird
that was impressive hunting with being
able to hunt with
bows and arrows made entirely from
native materials except
for a piece of wire cut from a fence
that was then hammered into the shape of
a projectile point
finding a plant called arrow plant which
you get your arrows
shooting a black curacao to get his
feathers for fletching
taking a yucca type plant and
pulverizing it
braiding it into a string waxing that
string with rubber from a rubber plant
lashing the fletching onto the shaft
making a glue from native materials with
which to put the things together
cutting a tree making a bow string and
then wading out into a river
and seeing a fish that i can't see and
shooting it with an arrow
it's good stuff yeah that does say
that's good stuff man
and you're also watching it you're
watching things change the thing i come
back to again and again about that
is there's an individual i love quite a
bit down there
who he was explaining to me one time
about the white lip peccaries
that they haven't been seeing a lot of
white-lipped peccaries
and there's a fear in his village that
the shaman
from a neighboring village has grown
jealous
of his village so this neighboring
shaman is mad
at my friend's village because they're
so prosperous and
he is like a pig a pig-like animal yep
it's a yeah it would at a passing gland
a javelina is a collared peccary people
in the southwest
like in arizona and western texas are
familiar with javelinas
um yeah that's a collared peccary then
there's a slightly bigger more
gregarious version called the white lip
peccary
and he said that he was concerned that
this shaman and neighboring village had
grown jealous of his village
and had locked up all of their peccaries
in a mountain and they had their own
shaman trying to to develop the
necessary skill set
to release their herd their peccaries
from that mountain and i'll point out
that you can email
this individual if you have a problem
with what he's saying
so they are at a real crossroads yeah
and it's been a long crossroads but to
intersect
to intersect them at this place at this
moment was fascinating
yeah what a time to capture the
experience on film
and i'll uh i'll get the specific
episode information from you afterwards
and we can put those
in the show notes as well that'd be
great yeah well
last question for for this conversation
actually maybe second to last
for people who want to reconnect attempt
to reconnect
with nature whether by themselves or
with their families
i've also spent quite a bit of time in
south america and
other jungle based communities and you
do see this
what they sort of take for granted it's
almost you mentioned david foster
wallace it's like the old fish that
swims by the two young fish and says
how's the water boys and they
kind of nod and go by and they go what's
water right so to them
them referring to the communities in
places like you mentioned the idea of
being separated from nature
is just inconceivable yeah they wouldn't
just they wouldn't describe that problem
yeah it's just the problem itself would
be hard to
explain so for people who are listening
to this
and want to reconnect feel
engagement kinship with nature
what would you suggest it's interesting
you ask because we're working on a book
right now about
kids kids in nature kids and
nature but you could also say kids in
nature and i've been thinking
about this a fair bit because there's a
risk of making
we're talking about these extreme forms
of nature right the jungles of south
america
arctic alaska we're talking all these
extremes and you can create this problem
where people think that
engagement with nature needs to be a
radical
version i think that as i've pondered
this a lot lately
i think that there's some things that i
find myself trying to do with my kids
that aren't
for kids only and i think you need to
start trying to
develop the mindset of what it is to be
like native
and i'm not trying to take away i don't
mean native in terms of that you'd be
native americans say or native alaskan
or amber indian i don't mean that i mean
native like the
of trying to belong to the a place we
associate ourselves
belonging to a fan base belonging to a
social media community
belonging to a municipality belonging to
a political persuasion
but if you want to start thinking about
yourself as belonging to nature
start a list of all of the first define
what your yard is
it could be the grounds on an apartment
building where you live
it could be your yard whatever it is
start a list of every bird
get a good bird book get the sibley get
sibley's guide to
birds of north america if you live in
north america how do you spell civilly
sibley i believe he's sibling yeah he's
an illustrator and ornithologist
s-i-b-l-e-y
all right get that book and start a list
of every bird
that you see
from your property from your place where
you live from your balcony or whatever
it is
a list of everything you see and be and
allow yourself to count things that you
see way off
so if you're in an apartment in new york
and you can see out over the hudson and
you catch
a seagull count that and allow yourself
to count every bird
that you hear and then do a couple other
things
uh acknowledge the
solstices and the the equinoxes on those
days acknowledge what is happening
that today the day is as long as the
night
or today is the longest day the sun will
shine for the longest time tonight or
this will be the shortest day the sun
will shine the shortest amount today
and tomorrow the sun will start marching
back in another direction
ask yourself when you turn on your
faucet and water comes out
where did that water come from did it
fall as snow
rain where was it collected is it from
an aquifer what feeds the aquifer
and then ask yourself when it goes down
the drain
what is its path to where it hits the
ocean
and make a mental map of if you were to
take a piss in your yard
make a mental map it would flow into
this ditch and that ditch flows into
that stream and that stream flows into
that river
and that river flows into that estuary
and that estuary drains into that part
of the ocean and make a mental map and
look at that map
these are some of the things you can do
sitting in your at your desk
and i think that as you do these things
and think about them you'll start to
realize that you're
a participant in something and you'll
start to realize
that there are things that are extremely
reliable the solstices
like the solstice equinox there's things
that are so
unbelievably reliable and there's things
that are so chaotic
like you're passing the coming and going
of birds
as you do those things you'll find
yourself feeling
a part of something that's way cooler
outside of being a part of your
community and family that's way cooler
than being
part of a fan base or part of a social
media network
do that and then go down to south
america
but start start at home man
like you're never gonna understand if
you can't like just understand like
where you're sitting and how it fits
like get some awareness you're like
you're in nature man you're in nature
it's just we're we're trained to not
notice it you know it makes me think
of the thousands of tussocks that i
walked over
never actually getting down on my
stomach and looking at one yeah
plant your face in one of those things
yeah like like very lo like barry lopez
describes
those are great recommendations uh i
think i will actually
look at the water investigation later
this afternoon
it's fascinating yeah i haven't gone so
far as to make my kids memorize it but i
i try to talk about it a lot well steve
we're gonna hopefully do a round two of
this that's the plan i would love to
yeah and is there anything else that you
would like
to mention any closing comments any asks
or requests of the audience of course
people can find
a lot of what you do at themeateater.com
and we'll include all the social
at meat eater at steven ronella on
instagram at steven ranella meat eater
on facebook
is there anything else you'd like to say
before no it could be so yeah if i if
you allow it and i could be so uh
audacious as to yeah
just ask people to go to themeeter.com
you'll find not only stuff from me and
about books i've done but from
you know all of my great colleagues and
uh
our podcast network and daily stream of
written material and other things so
yeah please go there and check it out
and for everyone listening as mentioned
i'll also include
links in the show notes which you can
find at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast
to the website meaning steven's website
the podcast specific episodes of
the tv show books and many other things
that have been
mentioned in this conversation so people
can find those as well in one place
and steve what a pleasure to
catch up it's been a little while yeah
thanks for taking the time man it was
fun to talk to you as usual
you do a great job thanks man and we'll
uh we'll figure out scheduling for
a round two very soon and to everybody
tuning in until next time thanks so much
for listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow
dug up in the uh the world of the
esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
all form if you've been listening to
this podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep
and their mattresses which i've been
using since 2017. i have two of them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o
and they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped right to your
door at a fraction of the cost
of traditional stores so i'm sitting in
my living room right now and it's
entirely all form furniture i've got two
chairs i've got an ottoman and i have an
l sectional
couch i'll come back to that you can
pick your fabric
they're all spill stained and scratch
resistant the soap color
color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs
love seats all the way up to an 8c
sectional so there's something for
everyone
you can also start small and kind of
build on top of it if you want to get a
smaller couch and then build out on it
which is actually in a way what i did
because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use
the natural leg finish which is their
lightest color and
i dig it and i've been using these
things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky you don't need to
worry
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home with fast free shipping
and you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than
three months and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked
much better than i could have imagined
and i'm very very happy so
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear
listeners at allform.com tim make sure
to use the code tim
at checkout that's allforum.com tim and
use code tim
at checkout this episode is brought to
you by freshbooks
thousands of listeners and a lot of the
contractors i use
and my readers use freshbooks if you've
been thinking about turning your
part-time side business into a full-time
small business or big business for that
matter
you may be feeling some extra
uncertainty these days and
that's obviously completely natural
there are a lot of questions that can
come up how do you create a professional
appearance and experience
who can help you with support how do you
manage the billing and all of that but
still focus
on the primary work of your business and
on growing your business
freshbooks is an all-in-one invoicing
and accounting solution
it does a lot more than that that helps
you take your business from part-time to
full-time and it only takes
minutes to set up they have one of the
best sign-up goals
in the business i've seen very few
better they have been helping people
turn their passions into small
businesses for 15 years
and they can help you too i've met the
founders i've looked at this product
very closely with automated invoicing
billable time and expense tracking
and an intuitive dashboard that ties it
all together it's like having a
full-time financial assistant with you
every step
of the way you can create customize and
send branded and professional looking
invoices in about 30 seconds
you get paid up twice as fast with fees
as low as one percent using ach payments
on freshbooks
it's a fast easy and secure way for
clients to pay you for your work
and pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets freshbooks apart is
their award-winning toronto-based
customer service a real person picks up
fast
and will help you until you are
completely satisfied and have
your questions answered there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world right now
but your ability to build a business
that you're passionate about that you're
proud of
doesn't have to be one of those things
business owners all over the world rate
freshbooks as the easiest accounting
software to use
try it out check it out for free for 30
days at freshbooks.com
tim just enter tim ferriss in the how
did you hear about us section
again that's freshbooks.com tim to check
it out
and try it for free for 30 days one more
time freshbooks.com
you